and this is a talk by james robbins um
and
the title is
a proof of wealth inequality in quantum
mechanics using causal interaction
um
let's skip some of those okay first full
disclosure
um i don't know much quantum mechanics
um
a colleague of mine
through something about causal
interactions and for some reason i
realized it could be
used to prove those inequalities um
and the idea was was not new was to
recast interference between treatments
oh no
this is this is the past interference
between treatments is a question about
uh causal interactions that will unclear
later
and uh we wrote a paper um and richard
gill who's actually an expert in these
stuff
is an author also
and um
the proof's simple there are many
uh proofs of those theorem that are
simple so the only reason to add this
is to highlight the connection with the
current causal inference literature
um
and i don't necessarily mean the causal
inference literature
you've been hearing of it not the
graphical causal entrance which i'm sure
there's a whole different causal infants
literature based on kind of factuals
um and uh so
this will be
um
to those who don't know quantum
mechanics they'll be glad that i'm going
to go very
basic
to those who do
i can only say it's your chance to learn
about how
epidemiologists and statisticians think
about them
and how it relates in a way it relates
to physics here
okay um
so here's i'm going to go very fast
because you all know this because i
definitely given this
talk to
physicists so
okay so um short history
there's a non-uh non-intuitive
implication quantum theory
pairs of uh spin one half particles
could be prepared um
and if particle separates um we measure
the spins of both particles along a
common axis in space
and the measurement of one particle's
spin always
perfectly predicts the spin of the other
because the total angle momentum has to
be zero so the first particle spins up
then the spin of the other one must be
down like by conservation of momentum
um and one x uh explanation is the
measurement itself of the first particle
determined the spin of the second
even if physically separated by light
years
that would mean that was true that
reality in some sense was not local
what occurred at one place would affect
reality i either spin of the second
electronic or not
so
and einstein believed local realism he
argued both particles occurring with
them from their common source remember
they
were one thing they broke it to two
electrons different spins
um
that they're carrying with them from
their common source hidden correlated
spin outcomes which they will exhibit
when measured
and board disagreed with einstein and
his local realist assumption and neither
einstein or boer at the time i as i
understand it also if there are any
physicists here who want to interrupt
when i get
the story wrong feel free because
this of course i could come but
the einsteinian board realized the
hypothesis local realism was subject to
empirical tests and
bell showed that it was possible
and he proved their strict locality were
true there would be certain
inequality constraints
between measurable quantities that must
hold
quantum theory predicted these
equalities must be violated and
experiments found bella quantities were
indeed violated and einstein was wrong
and local realism is false
okay now relationship to name and
counter factual causality
we have two particles
we can measure the spin of each along
any axis
so the treatments x1 and x2
are going to be
our interventions so
and they're going to take three values 0
1 and 2 just representing different
angle three angles
x one records the angle x is in space
particle one is measured at x two
records the angle particle two is
measured at so we have a treatment for
particle one we call it x1 particle 2 x2
okay and our responses
is after we measure
the particle is it spin up
um if it is so if y1 when you treat
uh particle one with x1 particle two
with x2 y1 is going to be um that that's
the counter factual from our point of
view that
could have interference because i'm
making it depend not only on the
treatment that particle got x1 but it
may depend on x2
is the binary spin that's the outcome
which is one up if it's up
and minus one if it's down
and it turns out quantum mechanics you
always get either one or minus one no
matter what
angle you measure it at and y two x one
x two is
the spin for particle two one or minus
one
so in the language of deterministic name
and counter factual model
y l with l bead one or two is the
counter fractional response and particle
l under the joint intervention x1 x2
okay so then what's the experiment
we prepare n entangled pairs of
particles that just means they came from
the same place and they're
uh just what i said the total angular
momentum is zero
uh for each pair uh separately
um so investigator one flips a fair coin
and measures particle one in direction
one
heads and in direction zero if tails and
records y1 investigator two flips a
second independent coin and measures
particle two in direction two if heads
in direction zero if tails so if tails
they measure them both in direction zero
if
they measurement two different
directions
if um
x um
uh
if um
they don't do zero x one always measure
the non-zero measurement for x one is
always angle one the nine zero
measurement for x2 is always angle two
okay so then we're gonna see data so
we're gonna the data from the experiment
is gonna look at the joint distribution
of the spins one and two given the
angles x1 and x2
okay and by randomization
to get to the x1 and x2 is independent
of the counter factions in the usual way
although i think one of the talks
mentioned it one of the theories of
why bell's equality may not be whole
hold is called conspiracy which means
the whole universe has been constructed
to do weird things from the day of the
big bang or before but
that would mean people don't have free
will and can't randomize they're forced
to do what the universe wants them to do
because
but no one believes that
as far as i know
so so here we check so we're going to
assume we can randomize
so here we um
take uh so okay
okay so um so usually i'm just going to
give the results in terms of the
distribution of the counter factuals
because you've just seen that's connects
directly to the distribution of the data
under
the
given that you randomized x1 and x2
everybody with that right so i can say
the me
from an experiment i can learn in
hypothetical repetitions doing more and
more pairs i can learn
the meaning of these counterfactuals
because it's kind of nice experiment
okay
so now we're going to consider the
hypothesis that
the
outcome of particle 1
doesn't depend on how particle 2 was
measured
so that's you don't have interference in
our language and the outcome of particle
2
doesn't measure how particle one was
measured so that's a null hypothesis of
no interference
and remember these measurements across
the universe and just so you get the
punch line
they there is interference
okay
so in the language counter factual
theory this is a hypothesis of no
interference between treatments and
physics is referred to as the hypothesis
there's no local hidden variables come
to that
um
[Music]
it's the hypothesis of
local
hypothesis
uh
yeah
of
only local variables sorry
okay we shall see this hypothesis
experimentally testable
through bell zip and quality and one
test that's falsified
so why do we call no interference
between treatments that's what we call
it why do they call it um
local realism so okay so um
okay so as i said the particles can be
separated by light years
uh
you can't pass information what that
means faster than the speed of light get
to that later
so um
so
the hypothesis of no interference
between treatments implies reality um
do it
uh
the hypothesis note that reality is
local it's the other one that's i don't
know i kept saying that backwards okay
so so the hypothesis and no interference
between treatments asserts both local
this is correct locality and reality
okay it asserts locality because the
angle x2 at which part two is measured
has no effect of
on the uh spin
uh y1 x1 to particle one because there's
because we have no
um interference
and if we assume deterministic
counterfactuals it asserts reality
because the spin y x
of a particle measured along axis x is
assumed to exist for every x
even though only one's observed so
that's having a deterministic counter
factor
we only observe the one corresponding i
on which particles measures we say
when we observe the outcome under the
treatment
this is something bell insisted on
this is something bell insisted on many
times
the deterministic counter factual part
that's not an assumption that's a
theorem
you assume locality
yeah yeah i i'm not perfect let me do
the theorems i'm not that confused you
said it's a two or something made and
it's not true only one assumption is
maybe a locality assumption that's the
only assumption okay let me go on and
see if i do it wrong
when i get to it okay so einstein's
famous victim god does not throw dice
makes it clear that he believes in a
deterministic and not a stochastic
counter factual
and i think the service to
counterfactuals correspond to what
einstein called the elements of reality
local
and they were deter whatever
angle you measured at their outcome was
determined
in fact einstein deduced the existence
of deterministic counter factuals under
locality
why well consider the hypothesis
that uh yl for some
one or two is the realization of a
random variable
that is one with some probability
rather than being deterministic so
probability was you know between zero
and one
and minus one with some other
probability
that is a say you believe in stoke
stochastic counter factuals
well
um
given that einstein believed
in the hypothesis then of stochastic
locality he's going to rule out
stochastic proof
then he has
p1 the probability particle one
goes all you know uh this up or down
given x1 x2 doesn't depend on
the other place so we have no
interference so we're still going to do
no interference between treatments for
stochastic counterfactuals under this
assumption he deduced that god does not
flavor
dice from the fact that we always get a
negative correlation between y1 the
particle here
and y2 remember if
if they're measured along the same axis
i is the same axis
one's always up
and the other's down or vice versa
correlation minus one so they couldn't
be
having probabilities
that were different between zero and one
because if they did and it was only
nothing non-local could happen
how could they
always know what the other one is doing
okay so he so you can deduce
um determinism
from locality
maybe that's what you were saying
see i'm not as fat as you thought
okay so
proof of interaction between treatments
by results of causal interaction
okay so first date on correlation
between the two outcomes under uh
is going to be critical because as a
fact of nature that's the only place
where
um
where things are non-local where um
we have interference so i'm going to use
an outcome that looks at how often the
two outcomes are equal okay
so it's the end so it's the indicator so
i'm going to i have two outcomes i'm
going to take there the indicator
whether they're equal and so um
m x1 x2 is one if they agree both up or
both down m is one
otherwise zero if they go in opposite
directions
and i think this is a and suppose our
particles are in a maximally entangled
state they're certainly entangled they
don't know that it's maximal then
according to quantum mechanics it's two
particle system
the mean of the counter factual m i j
so it's
the product of y1 and y2 when you force
y1 to have angle measured angle i and y2
measured at angle j
is the this is just from quantum
mechanics which we don't know but this
is a fact
that it's the sine squared of the angle
between the delta i j is the angle
between the directions okay
and this result has been confirmed by
experiments in which the angles of
measurement were randomized
and notice in sine zero equals zero
if i measure them both in the same
direction
i get
that i get that they're um opposite that
their spins are exactly opposite as we
said already intuitively but i'm just
pointing out that formula agrees because
um uh
if it's
m is always zero is zero
um and that means they have opposite
spins remember opposite spins is m of
zero
okay
so we can take
the mean of this outcome the single
outcome now the indicator where they
have the same y one way to expand spin
we're gonna take its means as data from
the experiment so we did a huge
experiment and we really were able to
randomize
okay so this we show this as
incompatible with local
realism refuting the hypothesis no
interference and following a unit may be
taken to be a pair of entangled articles
so think of the unit now because this
could be part of the subtlety as a p as
the pair okay
okay
so
so theorem one is if
uh i'm gonna always take
mij as zero or one remember it's either
one if they agree zero otherwise
if i have m
when i measure
particle one and angle one and particle
two
at angle two if that's one but all the
other m's
both zeros a zero with two and a one
with a zero remember we never measure
particle one at two and we've never
measured particle two at one so these
are all possible treatments only four
things if this one's one and the rest
are zero
then the hypothesis of no interference
between treatments is false
so suppose the
um
um the uh hypothesis holds
then m12 is one
implies that
it uh implies that
both y one and y two are one because
they agree or they disagree so we're
thinking of one pair no random no
experiments is completely deterministic
okay
and i'm saying for i'm gonna from one
part one from one two particle unit i'm
gonna rule out
um
uh
if i get this
sequence of outcomes
then i know there's interference okay
um
okay um
and a lot of ways to see this is trivial
but let's do it
um i'll do it this way okay so let's
take case a they both agree because
they're up okay both spins
up that gives okay
so
so if okay
so suppose uh a holds then we know m
zero two is zero
and we know that y
two two is one because they're both y
two is up when you treat it we'll call
one and two one's a treatment for one
two three two
um
so uh
okay so
so we have to have minus one because
that's one and they disagree when i
treat particle one with zero so
particles so i get a disagreement well y
two
was one so y one when i treat it with
zero that's a zero
and two has to be minus one
or we want to have m zero two
equals one
now if we look at m one zero we know
that's zero because we assume there's
such a person
but we know y one one is one
and that implies by the same argument
that y two zero
must be minus one
but if y two zero was minus one
and m zero zero we also said with zero
that implies that um
uh
y one zero is
one because remember
um
and if you have um zero
and you measure the two particles at the
same angle they're perfectly
anti-correlated so i measured at zero i
got minus one for y two
that's because i learned that here and
by this being zero
but i know whenever y2 is minus one
minus one when i measure zero if i
measure both at zero y1 has to be plus
one
but we just deduced that y1 0 was -1
that's a contradiction
so
what went wrong the only thing could
have gone wrong is i should have had two
indexes that is local reality was false
it was in red
um you know because if i had it
um
if i allowed
each individual
y to depend on both i and j i wouldn't
have had all these constraints that led
to a contradiction so the contradiction
is
once again
if
when you treat both
their spins agree
but any other combination of treatments
anything with the zero
their um their spins disagree and that's
impossible
just by simple life you're gonna local
uh if um
the outcome doesn't depend on both
treatments because you get a
contradiction i did
um you know i did this case but the
other case
is
ice market
so
it
but
i can't i don't know the outcome of one
particle tonight
so if i knew there was such a particle
i've rejected
local realism but how am i going to tell
from data there's such a particle
so can we use the empirical data to
deduce there must be a unit satisfying
that because
that rejects
um well no interference therefore local
realism
okay
the answer is the following
suppose okay remember m i j forever
three g nine k is always zero or one
so
if if i could show you that
the the difference between these means
is greater than zero
then there must be a unit
with those
um
with all three of the anything that has
zero zero
and when you treat both being one why
well
i mean it's pretty clear but
by contradictions suppose there was no
unit
that had what we cared about okay that
okay
then for all units
so first you can see if
if
this guy
so okay so this difference
will always be zero
um if there's no such unit
because if we are subtracting
non-negative numbers so the only way
this thing could not be zero if if this
guy was one
but if it's one
that implies
at least one of these guys is one if we
have
no
um
if we have no uh
uh if we have no interference
um because
these guys
um
uh
this being one says i'll also get one
for the one of these
that agrees with
um the
that um
okay
uh
this is trivializes
so
um you have to have one of the other
um
uh m's be um
uh also one
because um oh because i said they can't
all be zero that's right my hypothesis
right they're
rejecting by contradiction says i can't
have this one and all these guys zero
right so at least one of them has to be
one
now look at this uh
look at the thing i'm trying to get
um
then this thing is gonna be less than
zero because if i ever have this one one
one of these has to be at least one of
these has to be one so i can never be
greater than zero okay so if there's
local reality
no interference um
uh
i
um this mean has to be less than zero
but quantum mechanics says or put
another way okay i already said you get
a trial uh quantum mechanics says
wherever i go that that's not true just
remember that the mean of m i j is sine
squared so if i look at these means
which has to be less than or equal to
zero under local
um
under no interference
um i get instead this one is this minus
zero because m zero zero always gives
you a minus because
those are the same angle they're
anticorrelated
um and then so all you have to do is see
if there are any angles that satisfy
this greater than
should be this plus the type of that
plus that
and it's easy to try some angles it's
not hard to find them okay
so the empirical facts
uh
mean the local reality is wrong again
that's because
this being positive those
uh implies there's no
individual
um
there is an individual sorry who has one
zero zero zero
and because there's such an individual
we saw that's incompatible with local
reality or no interference
okay so the point is i didn't really
have to do any probability here right
so there's been a lot of proofs like
that okay what's the connection okay
um two i already said it here
okay
um okay theorem two that's the one that
says
you wanna know
you wanna prove that someone has one
zero zero zero for outcome okay
that um
you could empirically test that from a
randomized trial so you can see the
counter factuals
by um because we know
you can falsify it
you can prove it because we know
that um
if it wasn't there
this mean
this uh
difference in means would have to be um
whatever the theorem was would have to
be less than zero and if it's not in
quantum mechanics okay so we disprove
local realism
and the point is theorem two the one
that says if you want to know one zero
zero
zero you can um
show that somebody exists that if
there's no local realism for some pair
if um those different that contrast is
greater than zero
and this to me was first uh
uh
written in the um
statistics literature
about the interaction of two treatments
so you're thinking of so the paper by
tyler there's one outcome and i have a
genetic exposure environmental exposure
of two genes i think i say two genes
below two genes
and he says if there exists a subject
with a response m
so for him m wasn't the product of
anything it's just the outcome of
whatever he's interested in do you have
a cleft width for this kid who's getting
two treatments getting two genes so it's
it's not about this it was not about um
interference between treatments it was
just about the effect of two treatments
one person
and um so you have two treatments
and he has some outcome m
and if m is one only when you get both
treatments with zero otherwise the
definition of this case is said to be
called an epistatic interaction
in genetics so this is something very
interested in geneticists
the outcome is cleft with two genes
m is clef lift one or zero so the
corollary theorem two that's our theorem
two of the prolines just due to
randomized trial shows that if x1 and x2
are randomly assigned it's possible to
empirically test
for such an interaction although the
test is not consistent it's the
conversation this false that is if you
get that expectation contrast greater
than zero you knew
that there was somebody who had an
um epistetic interaction there was
someone like that that's exactly the
result i used
um to prove um
uh bell's theorem okay and it wasn't
until he wrote his paper that one could
uh
it was known that you can impair
empirically falsify the hypothesis of no
epistemic interaction
so
the pro and so the above shows that the
problem of testing for an epistemic
interaction between two treatments with
a thing within a single subject is
formally equivalent to testing
hypothesis there's no interference
between treatments you know this is
considered interference versus
interaction and one person considered
quite different things in our field
that you can test the no interference
between treatments given to two
different subjects i and j these two
subjects are the two electrons that we
call a unit because we're looking at
matched pairs
so obvious so this is an obvious but
previously i think largely unrecognize
isomorphism between the literature and
treatment interaction order to turn
interference between treatments
um and at the time i wrote this was
probably no longer true this is back in
2012 a lot more was known about
interaction than interference so there's
a lot to learn here
okay
um
so we've already done that
so so there's something interesting to
notice here which i like is notice that
the sample space x1 for on vac2 prime
mechanics for x1 was 0 and 1 and for x2
was 0 and 2. that is when one and two
got treated they would never treat it at
the same angle
okay the statistician like this seems an
odd choice for the sample spaces um
as making both sample spaces
zero one is much more natural why do we
call one of the treatments two
and and then you could write everything
just substituting x2 equal one for x2
equal to
okay and if you look at the theorems i
proved they're both still true
so why did they do that and it's the
physics not the math the math of proving
the contradiction why is it the physics
because
if i had
put
if i had
put x2 equals 1 that would mean
m11 respon
means now
measure them at the same angle right
the same treatment
and we know that's always going to be
minus one
i know it's zero the
that can be anti-correlated then it's
called zero if they're not the same so
that's always going to be zero
so when i do my contrast i'm going to
get zero minus minus minus zero those
are the same those are the same so i
have to get a minus number so i can't
refute
um local
reality because i need the way i refuted
is that contrast was greater than zero
if i
don't have a different angle for one and
two even though the refuting theorem
doesn't say anything about that it's the
physics it says m11 is zero
okay
um
and now just to show you how it's all
goes together i'm gonna do a quick epi
example of using the exact same logic
of you know um interference
uh allowing you uh showing there's
interference
so here's another example they're
independent households of husband and
wives
husband and a wife
that's the unit okay
and there's no interference among
households they're like the experiments
they're like you know every two-part
unit of two particles
okay
and i want to ask you the question
there and um
i'm gonna ask a question we're having um
uh infectious disease and there's a
vaccination covet
okay are there households such that the
husband and wife
both remain uninfected if and only if
both vaccinated
okay that's a question that turns out to
be vel's theorem
because
let's x1 is one if the husband is
vaccinated zero not
x2 was one if the wife vaccinated zero
not i no longer need
them not to ever take the same value
because we're not doing physics okay
there's no anti-correlation with the
husband vaccinated like vaccinators
effective nature okay
okay so and x1 and x2 are randomly
assigned
so i'm going to define y1 to the next
one x2 is 1 if the husband is not
infected and 0 otherwise so y is 1 if
you're not infected um and say for the
wife i call life
2 that may be sexist but anyway i wasn't
thinking about at the time
okay and now i'm going to define m x 1 x
2 as simply the product of those two not
agreement okay i'm just going to use
that outcome
so i'm going to ask are there subjects
with m one one equals one but all other
combinations equal zero because if m one
one equals one by definition that means
both of these were one and therefore the
husband and wife
neither of them were infected that's the
only way to get m one one equals one
because i'm taking the product of
something that's one if you're not
infected
all these one or the other is infected
so if i could prove
that um
there's somebody
so
so one of the uh so
so if i could prove someone like this
existed in the population that means um
that the husband and wife are both
uninfected
only if they both get treatment one one
okay which is okay
well the answer is yes if
these the same contrast is greater than
zero because i just showed you in a
theorem there i can prove someone's like
that
if that contrast is bigger than zero
because m has the same sample space and
everything else they had nothing to do
with anything with
numbers okay
um
okay so
so so i just did an
interesting epidemiological example with
exactly
the same logic um
so
ruling it so from our point of view
ruling out no interference between
treatments also rules out local
realities
and
suppose the hypothesis
of local reality therefore is false
um have we um shown
that we have um
uh
um
interference well we have interference
by our definition these counter counter
factuals have to exist the outcome why
when you measures per se why for a given
person when you measure that person one
direction and somebody else in another
direction they have to exist and so if
we believe these exist then our
assumption of reality remains
that is these counterfactuals exist if i
tell you
the game i was playing as i i always
played that there was reality that is a
reality may depend on measurements
across the universe if there's reality
and um
that's given the reality of the name and
model there are those counterfactuals
the cause had it's in some sense affect
faster than white speed although
okay um
that's no exception and
now
um
it's a for okay so the bottom line is
there's a lot of interpretations of
quantum mechanics and these people that
don't believe
in these counter factuals even the
non-local counter factions okay
so
they agree local reality is not true
because that argument still goes through
because the argument was i made the
argument about a hypothesis
um
of local that
the outcome of the spin particle one
only dependent one i've come to spin
apart so only two and it was
deterministic
there was an element of reality because
of the anti-correlation the
probabilities but
the question is
uh
is the
model with counterfactuals
depending on both measurements
um
true or
i guess as the there are a lot of
theories i think the copenhagen theory
says
no nothing exists do you measure it sort
of aren't these counterfactuals but
okay and another interesting thing which
is is the no signaling signaling
assumption so we know that y1 x1
uh the way it's going to come out in
some sense depends on which angle you
measure the guy across the universe but
interestingly
that means there's an effect of two
but it has no effect on the mean
the mean of y1 x1 when i measure
2 in direction zero is the same
of person one whether i measure
two in um
in uh
another direction that is
the way we could this is something like
the name and null rather
sharpen all you don't get an effect
okay that's called no signaling and
that's important because if you could do
that you could transfer information
faster than life you could probably tell
your old your own grandfather because
here i am
many years later and uh what i measure
here can affect something
way over there and if it's faster than
life i don't know go back in time
so you could tell your own grandfather
so it's sort of probably pretty good
signaling there
okay do i have anything else to say
that's enough i'm not going to worry
about the rest of
okay
i'm done
okay so let me just because you ended
with the grandfather
and and and that awfully sounds strange
right um for someone to say
gosh if blah then you could kill your
grandfather right that would be pretty
bad
um that doesn't fall i just want to say
but that doesn't follow right
if we conclude
that
nature which i think is the correct
conclusion nature is not locally
causal or bell vocal
and you have to put some non-locality to
the physics one
easy simple way to do it is to put a
preferred foliation into the space-time
that's kind of
non-relativistic but that's the natural
thing to do
and if you do that you can still have
that causes always precede their effects
relative to that foliation there are no
causal loops there's you're all your
directed graphs are still acyclic you
don't get any paradoxes like that it's
very straightforward right you said
there was a you snuck in something you
didn't have a foliation and what else
you had something else no just the full
the you have a foliation and the and
and the causation is that causes always
precede their effects in that foliation
okay and therefore you can't get loops
okay
there's a foliation explanation it's
just the slicing of the space-time thing
so if i think there's a so if i think
there's a big bang
yeah that would make a foliation no no
it did take the whole
space time right picture it in your head
okay slice it into a set of
more or less horizontal slices okay
foliation just means divided into leaves
okay okay
it corresponds to what newton thought
the way time worked that there's an
instant of time and that incident of
time is globally defined
and it it cuts across your space-time
diagram if you if you put that in and do
your physics in terms of that you can
make sure you can't kill your
grandfather you can make sure that all
of your causal grafts are still acyclic
and you can violate bell's inequality
it's based like separately you can
evaluate no signaling also right uh you
can do it with or without signaling some
some well let's do it with
violating yeah you could file a signal
you'd be okay you still couldn't kill
your grandfather
you could just you could signal from
here
to somewhere to the side outside the
light cone but you couldn't have a chain
of signals that come back into a closed
curve because the
source of the signal and the receiver
would always have to be later in the
foliation so
nicely so if someone insulted me i could
tell someone across the universe who
haven't speak with that person's wife to
kill his wife yeah right but but but
they couldn't then signal back to your
grandfather's your grandmother and tell
them to kill your grandfather okay
any other
questions hi jimmy i i'm wondering why
the deterministic contractual matter
here i i understand in serum one it
matters because it's it's it's statement
is in terms of individual
binary but in
okay so
actually that's part of the thing i
didn't get to
um
i have
okay
um suppose
um
yeah so if you have um
non-local probabilities that what you're
asking about stochastic so
they depend on ing it depends on the
measurements but it that you have a
probability one's gonna go off and so
forth yeah so you can you that
inequality that you see
um
uh still implies that these guys can't
just depend on
one index i mean
one way to do that's just that because
there's one thing with probability one
because remember when you measure on the
same angle but but um in general well i
guess that doesn't even play in general
you can just do a coupling argument um
tyler and i wrote a paper on stochastic
counterfactuals you looked at it
you can it's not going to change
anything because you've been couple to a
world
where it's
deterministic or yeah because when you
mention local well you mentioned local
reality at the beginning
from the english statement there's
nothing to do with deterministic
counterfeit no i proved i understand
proof there was if you would walk past
can you go back to the slide
when you use english to describe local
reality
since i was saying it wrong you were
just saying
oh um oh
it's the point where i said einstein
proved
that uh
it was deterministic
yeah i don't know what einstein proved
but what you say is that the english
part is
doesn't matter
let's go through the logic again
the logic is we know as a fact
that
when if you measure two particles along
the same angle
they all one's always plus one one's
always minus one
now imagine we had locality locality
just means
that i measured particle one doesn't
influence particle two and vice versa
then i claim i've just proved
determinism
of the counter factuals because if these
two probabilities have nothing to do
with each other and they're not
deterministic
why do you always get perfect
anti-correlation that's the argument
that einstein did
so he decided the world
was determined and therefore every
within one of these electrons
the outcome it will have no matter what
angle you measure it at was completely
determined
but and that's the right argument if
there is
degenerate
dimension distribution does not mean
deterministic just means the joint
distribution is degenerate
right
yeah
two variables you were saying oh i don't
know
no because they don't have their joint
distribution is independent
if the measurement here is not i mean
when they're anti-correlated
exactly no matter what angle i measure
them they're exactly
anti-correlated
right if i measure them at both so
they can't be probability they can't be
stochastic probabilities i don't know
i mean what's the for the joint
distribution other than
uh
my y doesn't depend on what you measure
over there and vice versa
okay
just
what so that proves they can't both be
probabilities the probabilities only
depending on my measurement and this
person's measurement that aren't zero
and one now you want to say something
more so i was saying no more than that
what you may i i'm not saying i'm saying
that's what i was trying to argue
and i'm not sure what you're saying
above that
i think maybe this is a perfect
opportunity to discuss afterwards
because we're already a bit over time so
i think it's time to thank james and all
the speakers
[Applause]
[Music]